hey conan here this is my video response
to the what's in my purse video
uh i'm a little upset at carly bell 55
and i'll tell you why
uh earlier today i'm with my wife at
home and she's out in the garden she
gets stung by a bee
she's deathly allergic to bees she comes
running into the house
and she's swelling up her throat's
starting to close and she screams get my
epipen okay i rush to the kitchen
because we keep the epipen in the
kitchen
i go to grab the epi pen on the way to
the kitchen i pass my computer screen
and i just happen to see that someone
named carly bell55 has a what's in my
purse video i figure how long could it
be probably 30 seconds maybe 45 seconds
i could squeeze that in before i get the
epipen
so i start watching it
16 minutes
16 minutes long my wife's throat is
closing and i've got to watch this 16
minute video about what's in my purse
total waste of time
anyway the video ends my wife in the
meantime i guess
crawled
on her belly into the kitchen and found
the epipen herself
now i'm in the doghouse
because i stopped to watch a 16 minute
video and i'm like
i had no idea it was that long it's not
my fault
your problem should be with carly bell
55.
don't serve me with divorce papers
okay so hey just an idea next time you
make a what's in my purse video just
dump the purse over okay
then we all see and it's like 15 seconds
long and then people watching can go
save some lives
people are probably not alive now who
would be alive if you would dump the
purse
it's called being thoughtful
anyway subscribe to my
you know channel
you